good morning
good morning everyone my god I wasn't
ready for that count out I was in the
middle of stalking people and I think
Instagram Oh God who were you stalking a
kid who's some can you tell us one
person that you stalk or give us the
idea like what do you use it oh yes sure
i well i there's people like whose
stories I want to watch and I don't want
them to know I watch but then I have to
watch [ __ ] Jerry's stories on my fake
account cuz that [ __ ] block my okay is
he sore I mean I've been blocked for so
long I don't even know I was blown
asleep being I was clouded by Sheree is
the greatest achievement of my life I
was popping him before stories even
existence I don't even know what kind of
posts up there it's honestly what's the
opposite of premium content trash trash
and here's a message get a spoon
I need my ass I literally hit you you
should ask me you should be sponsored by
no he's so open about like hating me
like you know what I [ __ ] hate you
too you ugly [ __ ] oh my god I'm sorry
I've never said that I just like I hate
him spoke about it cuz I we're from the
same community but like you can
seriously like he might for breakfast no
seriously like I hate him I'm so glad he
let that I wouldn't run into him I have
me I'm juiced up now like for me I don't
know why I said things like I really
don't really watch his stories on my
Instagram I just like there's a bunch of
like bloggers I want to watch and like
make fun of them but I can't for my girl
in the job so I do it for my think again
well I'm really happy that you have that
vessel let me - oh my god I like have a
pit now honestly don't because your
didn't say anything that nobody yeah
welcome to the morning toast it is
alright and rainy Thursday and we're
just excited to be here Jack and I
almost didn't make it we took over your
turn like getting like into the highway
literally took a weird turn in the car
and like we were on the highway like we
almost hit a makeup and jacob was like
are you guys coming in really jacob
we're doing it really like unfortunately
yes i'm we have a terrible pit like
about they don't because i was like who
gives a [ __ ] i felt really good though
I'm happy for you like literally
somebody came over right I don't know
why I also act like this is the view and
like everyone's gonna because because
one cuz you are in the same community
like some
making moles or hat is like let's get
right into it because we have some
amazing boring stories for you today
just like recycled story it's like we
keep talking about the same [ __ ] [ __ ]
but it's almost like development I mean
I could talk about Megan Marco until the
end of time and what's going on this
week is just fascinating to me because
it's an asado because it's either like
she's so above it that it literally does
not matter she's marrying a prince like
her freaky family can do whatever the
hell they want or like she's freaking
out so I don't know how she's I don't
know how she's handling it yeah actually
I'm excited about the first story
because I think it's hilarious
um and then we also have Deere toasters
for you guys right and we did our
patreon episode oh yeah last night we
did a Riverdale sea series finished Ari
season finale we have where we talked
about all the stuff that we haven't
talked about since the last episode of
after L rest in peace and snitch was on
it with us so we because not everyone
watches her video we did half the
episode just snitch like you've probably
seen her before but like a couple of new
questions yeah we divvied it up because
we got like a bunch of demand for doing
after Dale and then some patreon members
were like I don't watch videos like we
just did it for everyone and everyone's
happy I'm like just please don't yell at
us like I can't take the yelling then
the second half is a Riverdale recap
that's actually funny enough that you
can enjoy even if you don't watch
Riverdale and you just like some steamy
vibe yeah it's very soon honestly I
thought the episode was just like really
fun and and I think you'll all really
enjoy it so patreon.com slash the
morning toast I think the champagne has
been in here since yesterday like we
just you're like oh my god there's a
hair where they could say what's a buzz
yeah it's from Thea from the other Oprah
sure
but before me to all that Jackie and I
are here to deliver the Fast Five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I could use a piece of
morning toast this is one of those days
saddling some sort of like emphysema
what is that I don't know it feels like
I have it what are you trying wondering
if anyone takes what do you don't really
see that you have like a cold okay so
you just wake up with like a swallow it
like a hurt swallow me for the past few
weeks because of my allergies and then
it's me
even worse by the fact that Zack insist
on sleeping with AC on so that's much so
I'm never gonna get better I'm just
literally my phone up to see that anyone
text me about like me being your Gossip
Girl I'm like so nervous literally don't
be no he's a freak of nature
wait oh that's such a great term so
everyone loved it yeah I think people
really like when we talk [ __ ] because
it's like it's so rare and it's okay no
one want to get in trouble these days I
don't I get in trouble and like there
are some people who like I hate but like
they don't know that I hate them or
there are people like who like I hate
but like our friendship could like get
back on the mend like I'm completely
done like if [ __ ] charity never talks to
me again and like my life will go on
trust me okay
first have a speaking of some other like
public shaming Gossip Girl Hilary Duff's
speaks out after publicly shaming her
neighbor for smoking okay since erm
stories are why uh let this be a lesson
to all do not mess with Hilary Duff I
mean I'm pretty sure we already knew
this but after the way after the way
she's down to the Bahamas after the way
she took down Paulo JEP the way she
treated me and my lovely friends in the
Bahamas she was a nice to you oh my god
if I take a picture with you guys we
just stop staring at me and we're like
of course but like sometimes you just
want to stare at a celebrity you really
don't want to picture anything
it's fascinating okay what did she write
the 30 year old actress took to
Instagram on Wednesday to vent about her
neighbor Peter Addison quote calling all
New Yorkers with [ __ ] neighbors
really open to any advice you have the
younger star said via her Instagram
stories my neighbor's smoke cigarettes
and weed all night long my apartment
reeks seriously what do I do
however the Lizzie McGuire celeb didn't
stop there quote we know your parents
pay your rent we know you've never
worked a day in your life must be nice
she continued have some respect for your
neighbors who work hard to live in that
building
don't be a dick dude and put your trash
down shoot damn so obviously when she
put his name up like I went searching
for him on like these four gonna
Instagram and like I was mortified to
say we have like a ton of mutual friends
so I need to find him no no because my
beginning like a ton of friend requests
I need to like not be so obvious yeah
like who is he how did he get into
Hilary Duff's building no but I actually
Hilary Duff I can um I can relate
because in the last building that I
lived in our neighbors smoke pot all day
long not only did the hallway smell our
permit actually never smelled just the
way the draft worked it never hit us but
everyone thought it was our apartment
that was causing this so it was a case
J'Accuse situation juice and what did I
do
we tattletale and said exactly whose
apartment that it was so then last night
the police were called it gets worse
because Hilary Duff's boyfriend Matthew
koma I think his name is barged into his
apartment that's our next story Hilary
Duff's neighbor told cops her boyfriend
attacked him like he he says that he
came into the apartment the boyfriend
and like tried to hit him in the head
but missed and then the dealer shoved
him out and called the police
well like this is like like we live in
the city like neighbors aren't a thing
you know what I mean
totally like everyone Minds their P's
and Q's hmm go some with our life but I
guess if your apartment is starting to
reek and you have a child like then go
haggling and you have a big platform I
don't know I just feel except one isn't
outing this person on a really big part
even though he seems like an [ __ ]
no totally like that's just so mean even
though like I definitely would do that
no you wouldn't really I love to wield
my platform against people but you
wouldn't lose someone's real name but
you would go tattletale
I think honestly the solution to most
problems is to tattletale we were told
not to do it in middle school but they
taught you well but then put that in
your ass snitch and that like goes
against everything we've ever said on
the show but like cinches ain't sure but
sometimes cinches is because someone
should just need to bring the problem to
the authorities and let you know mm-hmm
let justice serve itself yeah that's
just my my two cents
Hilary Duff my also who knew that Hilary
Duff had a boyfriend she's like I was
dating no-name weenies right and here's
another one Matthew koma and he also is
you know a no-name wienie who's a little
aggressive
totally but you know he's defending
Hillary and her kids so like that's
admirable Hillary Hillary like when you
think of Hillary you think of Clinton or
Duff circumstances I think I've cleared
it then I'm gonna go Clinton yeah just
cuz it was more like do you think Hilary
Duff's upset you only spells with one L
do I think Hilary Duff's upside no
because she actually seems like the type
who like is an actor because she likes
the work not being a celebrity I totally
agree and it's crazy the channel is
exact she's she a she does it for the
craft it's crazy shows in New York
though like because they film younger in
Brooklyn I know I love younger do you
watch I do it's so good it's so good and
like I'm not gonna lie I don't love
Sutton Foster like she kind of pissed me
off but she's perfect for the role like
she's perfect for the role but like I'm
more soul of like the picture he paints
like neither apartments are so cute and
the like the decor in the office and
like everyone's outfits like it's really
wealth styles and also like they go out
in New York it's the only show on TV
that makes New York like look glamorous
these days because anything else we have
is girls and broad city was in Newark I
wouldn't say that those are the picture
of glamour know my real house is in New
York piece yeah but that's that that's
reality
but I'm saying a fiction nonfiction show
yeah no no for some reason like they
always make in New York look terrible
yeah like and I mean I'm not gonna lie
sometimes New York Times look terrible
but you know there's a way to make it
look nice to like make it like exciting
do comments and girls are like highly
realistic same with broad city like the
way that people are aged live yet no not
talking on the apartment I'm talking
about the social scene like when they go
out and girls it's like to some dingy
bar everybody's sweating and like on
Molly and you know maybe that happens in
some parts of New York but that doesn't
speak for the whole city I agree I feel
under represented by girls yoga girls
good thing it's over yeah watch it it's
so crazy what a turn it took because
they really did speak first everyone won
like every Emmy when she was like
getting weight at the doctor and she was
like well you might want to detect it
close for so like for like two years it
was so incredibly like on point like for
post-grad girls living in the city just
like and everyone was represented like
the chubby girls the spoiled girls like
everyone had a voice and like I just
like the rise and fall of Lena Dunham
has been amazing to watch it's really
it's it's so weird did you read her
thing in vogue about Jack Antonoff like
she did it just like a spread in Vogue
no and then she spoke a lot about the
breakup she didn't mention Lourdes or
anything but she was just like we were
together for like the last like six
months like we never spoke to each other
so what entry so she was literally was
being Hannah I like she's being so
[ __ ] dramatic like the pain was
unavoidable it's a kind of pain or you
sit in your kitchen looking at one
another thinking what are we to next
like it was so [ __ ] dramatic but I
loved it that's so crazy no I didn't
even hear about it actually
no she look pretty in the pictures I'm
not lying I know
Wow look at Vogue okay so Hilary Duff
dresses for Hilary Duff and her
oh I've been randomly selected to
participate in this short survey to win
a $10,000 gift card for Amazon do what I
do it okay oh you're real pro real virus
know about totally this iPad is clean go
away
oh my god I'm literally in the midst of
a virus just keep pressing back like a
hundred times help
Hiep star club oh my goodness
oh my god okay cnz well no no it's not
TMZ our third story is about Chrissy
Teigen and John Legend welcoming baby
number two quote somebody's here
honestly like too many good things keep
happening to the Teigen Legend family
like enough that I want something bad to
happen to them but like the world works
we're like good things happen to people
and bad things happen to people like
where are the bad things because I think
nothing bad happens them you never know
what goes on in someone's private life
but I feel like for a while like
BuzzFeed was really keeping these two
relevant and now it is comments by
celebs that is just keeping propping
them up like I want to say something
about comments by celebs because I feel
like I had a large hand in like making
them what they are like when I did a
whole thing on them and they like 30,000
followers in like the next day they had
70,000 and like today they have 200 I'm
like it's definitely a great concept
like they're like so up celebrity's ass
is like trying to get their attention
it's like a little annoying yeah but but
sometimes I get annoyed by it and I over
all I love it and I think that their
toasters and it was such a um and the
work that they're doing is so important
I can't believe there wasn't a page like
that before
and like there are so many now cheater
brands that are doing like Chinese
cobbler yeah I totally don't even know
each but comments ice loves really does
and sometimes it's like too much in the
circle of like John Mayer Andy Cohen
Kelly Ripa highly rapid Mark Consuelos I
don't care about like it's like their
goal from the Instagram account is -
bartender watch happens live right but
then they posted yesterday because
you've been told Steven Tyler comments
in an I'm ones post which I would have
never seen we're blunt either meme about
Steven Tyler and soon Tyler competence
and like he was in on the joke and it
was so funny so via that reason then I
was like so glad for comments but that's
why the the premise of it is really good
like just seeing random celebrities
commenting on random things is epic but
like they're getting a little too hyper
focused I'm like one click in the city
agree of like Kelly Ripa consuelo's Andy
then Jake the sign fell oh yeah
it's like branch out Jessica Seinfeld
yeah she's a part of that crew I read
these books Sarah Jessica Parker like
girl got it oh so someone said that
Chrissy came out saying she battled hard
with postpartum depression so so she has
gone through stuff that's true and what
oh my god I take it back her dog died
and her dogs the instrument I mean the
caption she wrote on her in scrims like
I'm sorry Jaime cry and like I read it
all the time I go back and read it also
Chrissy when we reported that she like I
don't know if she battled with
alcoholism but just like alcohol in
general relationship and alcohol
she had fertility issues okay I'm sorry
I take it back like she has a good life
it's well-rounded with good and bad
things right and you know I think she's
definitely someone who looks on the
bright side because she makes the most
of the positives
yeah and minimizes and I get it and I
totally forgot all of those things
because she does such a good job of
being positive so true and I just really
forgot about the dog
like literally I go back and scroll down
on her and screaming Reid they captured
about her dogs like it makes me cry I'm
sorry you should just save it to your
collection so you don't have to keep
scrolling we're water saving to
collection everything in my collection
is saved by accident no you have that
too but then it's interesting because
you can use your insights to see how
many like a certain photo of yours how
many people have seen their collection
yeah but like it's not easy to account
for 30% of it being big and like it's
just complete accident
well I just love collections I'd use it
for like herons Boeing like and video
said I don't I can't watch right now
because I don't like watching videos
with my smart because it's bothersome to
others oh you know what I'm I'm above
that like I'm listening to a video with
sound on like [ __ ] off you know yeah I'm
aware that something that you feel looks
like if I don't watch it in the moment
I'm never gonna watch it so like sorry I
don't have headphones like you're just
gonna have to watch with me
Zach does that too and it's just I'm
surrounded by listening to video said
I'm not watch so like I do it when me
and better like watching TV and then he
doesn't I'm like are you kidding I'm
watching something okay so you are Zach
because that's what I texted me it's
very easy road like I'm time set oh give
me one of those waters Oh
yesterday we were smaller it's sponsored
by Olin spring today England today it's
Aquafina clearly our budget went down
look yesterday's bottle I was like might
as well not even be it's like so thin
like what is the point was it even about
it why don't they just give you a pilot
eco-friendly but like well you know what
I remember it's all you have right
so enjoy it okay dramatic next story in
the saga dramatic the saga continues
Megan Marco confirms that her dad won't
attend the wedding so Kensington Palace
release the final and ultimate statement
because it is now at what time for I
didn't you and that's when we said that
this case is closed
but it's Thursday at almost noon it
seems like they're ruling with an iron
fist and just be like you can't come
even if you want to like we're done with
you right and it's like I feel like
flights to London our book now there's
no way he's flying private if he doesn't
have his ticket he'll never get it so
it's over this is like so beyond sad and
like for as much as we've spoken about
her someone did a post in the toaster
yester that was such a good point
they're like wait
- Claudia Jacquie like Megan Marco and
like it's very confusing music is like
hi ginger
right like I'll tell you I'm not her
story and I'm enthralled by her but like
I like her are you secretly journey
about Megan Markel when I woke up on
Thanksgiving morning with my Daily Mail
news notification that these two were
engaged
I wish cooked to the core obsessed this
was also hallmark season I had literally
just watch her in a movie and I never
had taken their relationship that
seriously because the Royal like crown
doesn't give us nothing on just
boyfriend girl her relationship so I was
shook and I just was so invested Mike
Deal or No Deal
all the stuff in like this hallmark
actress is going to be a princess and I
was just so happy for her and like I
felt like they were so in love and then
there were a couple style choices I
didn't agree with the hemline but I felt
bad saying anything we said something on
the show and like I felt without it we
got back we got some plaque but then
Gary Jannetty made it socially
acceptable to question Megan Markel
total and all hell broke loose I'm sorry
and so I like her I'm shook by it the
hallmark of it all but I wish she would
step it up in a couple little areas yeah
especially in the south that she was her
hemline
yes I'm but I feel like here's what I'm
gonna say about Megan Marconi depending
on what her wedding dress looks like
will make or break her for me I think
she has an amazing wedding dress I will
take back everything mean that I said
about her because a person's wedding
dress is like just like a quintessential
Ike it's about the ultimate it like like
for the personification if I start to
the sea and it means like where
everything at the end that comes
together a conglomerate
no it's more like a not like a
compilation sort of it's just like a a
rendering of her style right and it's
like no your wedding dress is just it's
nothing about is your style so my
wedding dress was long-sleeve because
I'm not a [ __ ] but then I was like a
little off the shoulder he's like I can
get a little sassy you know yes so
whilst depending on what she does the
jury is still out on Meghan Marco for me
but like I love her but you know I'm
allowed to question so at this moment in
time officially her dad is not coming to
the Wilma nation thank you thank you to
all of the toasters okay also like just
because he's not in like going now
doesn't mean he's not flying to London
and like crushing the wedding like any
family that she's like ashamed of no I
think if he was going to London and like
he would be walking her down the aisle I
just I just hope that like she's like
this must be so overwhelming for her and
then she's so grateful for her mom
because her mom is like the only normal
one yeah like shows up on time Burberry
Roberto I was like gonna say that you
know class act
yeah like the moms really pulling out
the stops like in order to make it seem
like they're somewhat normal to the
Windsors but I feel like everyone like
who's watching this billions of people
around the world like it's very
relatable you know everyone has family
drama around their wedding yeah but like
there's always to be above it right but
like the toasters were saying like
honestly Megyn Marcos family stuff like
makes me feel so much better about my
own family wedding drama no for sure
family wedding drama in general it's
just like so dramatic and literally this
morning Jackie's learning all about it
but I am you guys how do people do it I
had like it for just hasn't even started
yet I'm just trying to get a number so
that I can start looking at venues and
then Jackie just found out that the
average price per person in the city is
$100 per person that's why my venue
didn't charge me per person that's what
I need to find a way I knew that won't
charge me for a person but like I'm just
and ever since like big said that like a
200 person wedding is a circus like I'm
shook how would a Jackie the Tres I
don't even have it I don't have nothing
except for pits and anxiety so in a
player and planner with this letter for
planning that's a step
yeah and he makes me feel like less
anxious about stuff cuz like all this is
just part of the process and like a
million girls do this it's true a day a
year young people get married a year
it's a wild industry like if you're
working in the bridal industry like
you're cashing in
this is what's crazy about the bridal
industry it's like aside from the people
who you know like work in bridal shops
or wedding dress designers or wedding
planners it's like all brides like you
go in and out of the bridal world like
no one's a permanent like I'm there in
the bridal well yeah I mean last year I
was getting invited to every bridal gala
now no one wants me great an old married
[ __ ] but isn't that so crazy it's like
no this year of your life where you're
like in this industry and then hopefully
you'll never be and again right no it's
like you're Affleck being a bride is
fleeting like it's not a permanent thing
I thought no one isn't permanent I like
when I went to the Reem Acra Bridal Show
was like everyone except for like the
editors who work in weddings like
everyone in that room like will not be
there next right no I I went last year
haven't been invited back since um I saw
this dress like I loved really yeah it
was a white background yeah yeah so I
don't know where to find it but and
where to find it on sale like maybe they
can like stain it yeah yeah I spilled
ketchup on it no I mean I want to go
weddings are shopping I think that'll
make me way more excited and I feel like
I I have no real idea of what I want but
now when I envisioned it like I think I
have to do off-the-shoulder because
that's my signature and because like
that's the most flattering on it and
because your style icon did it too
no no like I mean like off the shoulder
like shoulder you had a boatneck she had
a boatneck you guys she's such a boater
style icon I just can't you know what I
really can't wait for like when I was
planning my wedding everyone was like oh
Claudia like all the sisters like we're
like you're so dramatic just like so
many people like oh really is to do that
right so expensive I mean so extravagant
now you're starting to understand are
you sorry you're still a factors out of
your control
yeah and so I'm just trying to be like
the best bride that I can be for
everyone around me and then you know
what I think I think something that I'm
going to do is just keep everyone out of
it and just make these difficult
decisions by myself it's see like you're
gonna be spending so much money you're
gonna have a Pitt about making a
decision without consulting like a
hundred people and that's like a
blessing and a curse cuz you're like
everyone has annoying opinions that like
don't make any sense and like our
self-serving like when my friends come
you know what I mean like yeah so like
it's both this is towards that it's a
sword that swings both ways
okay also someone said that 2.1 million
couples 2.3 million couples get married
a year and 876 thousand divorces a year
okay that's better than the 50% odds
that I had heard yeah so that's not
really the divorce rate is going down
like a fee like it was going up and then
I feel like it's gonna start to go down
because I feel like it's generational
like so many of us now have grown up
with parents of divorce that it like
makes you really not want to get
divorced right so you try even harder to
knock it right and then like then we'll
be the generation that stays together
even though we don't angry and then our
children will be like I wish my parents
got divorced right no way it's a
pendulum it's really crazy right the
metaphor of the pendulum like always
fits the pendulum like the swinging ball
no no like the and then it swings back
yeah yeah yeah I just think it's
interesting I learned but in physics wow
you're such a physician okay last story
Taylor Swift stalker sentences six
months in gym the man arrested for
stalking him bar burglary inside Taylor
Swift's apartment last year has been
sentenced the Manhattan district
attorney's office tells enews them
Mohammed Jafar pled guilty to attempted
burglary in the second degree on Monday
May 7th he was promised a sentence of
six months in jail and five years on
probation where he has to continue
mental health treatment in Michigan
the judge sentenced know they like the
sentence was weird the judge said but on
Wednesday morning May 16th to the jail
time in probation that was promised last
week last March too far was arrested in
Swift's new york city building for
burglary stalking and trespassing these
stalkers are getting out of control
totally I long for the days where people
just like stand on street corners and
look at you like now they're getting
into your bed and like using your
vibrator like it's crazy no and like
taking your purses no it's just like
it's so invasive like it's wild how
little privacy celebrities have and it's
like I feel like in New York City
because when we were saying Rihanna got
burger eyes you legit said that would
never happen in New York City however
here we are it was in New York City
well here's the thing she lives in the
townhouse so no she doesn't
ships in an apartment building no but
she also has a townhouse was it in
Tribeca on Franklin it's clear she rents
a townhouse for like 60 grand a month
it's unclear switch has not commented
publicly
yeah she's Chu home so but it's it's
different like living in a doorman
building with lots of apartments like
sleep safe knowing that like okay if
someone the odds if someone wanted to
vary lies they have to get past I have
two German at all times the DIA pets
both of them then they have to know that
all I think it's like I live in like a
35 floor building that I live on a
certain floor and then of like the ten
apartments on my floor that I mean that
one and then there's you get past my
three locks and Theo and bed I sleep
very good whereas he live in a house in
the suburbs knock knock you're dead you
know yeah I'm like your your ATT alarm
system it's just not it's not cutting it
you're awful and you have a watchdog
which helps ya who's being such a
watchdog that's mine who's been crazy
after you guys left really he being an
angel while we were there literally dead
on the rug like just sleeping so soundly
so before we come in - dear toasters I
need to talk about what I also did after
you guys left and I watched a movie that
is the best movie of my life I like it
dreamt about it I'm like living in the
world of the movie and I can't get out
of it oh don't go tell I'm watching it
again once we get home it's called the
kissing move it's Marga made me watch it
and it's like you'd like to send ins
like Disney like vibe like it's for
two-year-olds don't give away too much
because I don't know it's about I love
watching a movie where I'm not gonna say
when I'm about to watch it's an
unbelievable movie it's the best movie I
think I've ever seen that's I didn't
love the ending but I didn't care
because I was like loving the movie so
much except I thought the girl Joey King
who I just found out as Jamie Kings
little sister was horribly miscast she
never brushed her hair the whole movie
it was infuriating it I thought it Margo
told me and in Kendall she's like that
movie was so good why did that girl
brush your hair it's the only thing
you'll be able to realize that and by
the way the two protagonists are dating
in real life I just saw them in it sir
I'm obsessed that guy is so hot like I
think he's 12 and they're like wanna
marry him and I think you know how Diaz
I think he's playing Heath Ledger in a
biopic like that's how hot he is
Wow except he was with Heath Ledger like
put some Oliver is in serum but I think
it's opposite I need you to watch the
movie
maybe he's shining at the part maybe the
only problem I have with the movie is
that the the male protagonist who was so
[ __ ] hot was it never in it I like
wanted to see more of him not Joey King
like I wanted more Noah not Elle oh my
god it's so good you have to watch it
how about you today
I'm gonna murder straight-up said that
they're sisters Margo's ass snitch I
don't know what your smart is live for a
living
yeah let me just google it really
preferably because it made a lot of
sense
they're definitely Google dude also
they're like 50 years apart
just kidding more like 15 but no I just
I can't say enough about this movie like
kudos Netflix and then I was just doing
so much research the movie literally
came out yesterday
and on her Instagram story I was looking
at her and scrap straight from 24 hours
ago she was celebrating she just got to
1 million and then when I was looking at
a letter she was at one point 1 million
so I guess like Netflix has that
favorite literary her movie came out for
24 hours and she already got a hundred
thousand Instagram followers I mean
that's like we're I yeah exactly
oh my god I love the movie I hope it
like I really hope it's successful I
hope they all make a lot of money and
they do a sequel where like they live
together in Boston are you ruining
things
no like I everyday that is no bearing on
anything and also you were in Riverdale
for me so stop and now I didn't
yeah you doing it for yourself no I
stand by and then looting it and then
you proceeded to ruin it for everyone
here talk more about the kissing booth
like it's such a good movie like I want
it to be like in high school like in my
bedroom like texting no I like I wanted
to be her do you know any who wants to
be in high school
well when actually I guess high school I
would go to everyone in the movie was
rich as hell right and there wasn't even
like they always had such nice houses
and they didn't worry about money and I
was like I want to live there that's
nice that's always nice
Jackie it's the best okay I'm gonna
watch it tonight everyone has to watch
it and then let's all recover tomorrow
in the testers okay let's go on to dear
toasters because there are people out
there ambassador post in the in the
toast in the morning toasters Facebook
group there are people out there who
need our help so are you ready to help
them no you don't look ready
I'm not give me two seconds okay why
don't you prepare because they need your
help Claudia they're calling on you the
toasters I'm ready I need your advice
your sage wisdom this first one is
called men are trash I was recently
attacked opinion Jacobs entourage now
there's been neither is that Zach no get
CEOs not trash oh my god of course not
and like
but some mana seminar I was recently at
a work conference and on the last night
they threw a huge party with an open bar
I ended up meeting this cute guy and we
hit it off oh my god this is scary
workplace romances workplace drinking
you guys oh don't do it we were dancing
like twirling me around on the dance
floor of a piano bar and was getting
handsy but in a good way we ended up
being on the same floor of the hotel
about three rooms apart which is wild
because it's a 25 for hotel and I went
back to his room with him we were just
laying on the bed for a while fooling
around but he kept pulling away I flat
out asked him why he wouldn't and he
ignored it instant red flag went up so I
asked him if he had a girlfriend he kind
of chuckled waved his ring finger at me
and said well I'm not married then he
started spewing how he doesn't know if
she's the one and she'll never knows
what happens at the conference days of
the conference etc I said I could never
do that to another girl and got the hell
out of there stat go-to girl we were all
wearing name tags at the conference so
obvious when I room I looked on Facebook
you know the girlfriend did you know
their girlfriend not only is this guy in
a long-term relationship but he's also
engaged so now I don't know if I should
mention her to let her know that her
fiance is the worst human ever or it's
not my business and I should stay away
oh my god she got involved when my
friends are all saying they would want
to know if it was them
what should I do I'm always of the
mindset where like don't put your nose
in other people's business like you have
vital information and like that girl
needs to know but also like if he's that
obvious like in front of co-workers like
not even ashamed like to be grabbing
some other girl in public like there are
other girls too and like they could come
look forward to also this is horrible
but I would say don't do it because
here's what's gonna happen honestly
because you don't know this girl you're
gonna write her to strand a message
she's gonna freak out she's gonna ask
him he's gonna deny it she's gonna
believe him and nothing's you're the
villain and nothing's gonna change
except now he'll know that she's on to
him and then hold start getting away
with it better instead of being obvious
about it because right let her quieter
yeah this is like a classic case of Tom
LuAnn and Bethenny like Bethenny became
the villain when she was just trying to
do the right thing and this girl isn't
even you don't know her so it's not like
you owe heard the truth or something
right and yeah she'll probably want to
know but I'm gonna tell you that she's
not gonna believe this random person on
Facebook no good deed man like anytime
you stick your nose in [ __ ] like it's
just backfires but like literally all
you're trying to do is help right that's
that's why I don't help people know I've
learned timing timing
literally stop trying to do nice things
because it's it doesn't or never pays
off and like bites you in the ass mind
your own business don't expect nothing
from nobody and don't do anything for
anyone else just like take care of
yourself and you don't know these people
so you know let them and if he's a real
scoundrel
you know like maybe they were Louis out
or she knows and she's ignoring it and
she's pulling louann's right just not
your problem be glad you got out of
there when you did okay next up baby
drama my husband and I have been trying
to get pregnant for a year and have had
no success it has taken a toll on me
mentally and I'm honestly fighting with
myself to not be sad every day my best
friend and I have been talking about
babies for years and I told her my
future boy and girl names years ago
unless it looks that she would
understand that those names are freakin
off-limits
well this is so Sex in the City Sheila
Sheila I know this is serious matter
oh my god she's recently announced her
pregnancy I'm posted on Instagram with
the gender name of the baby and surprise
she's using my boy name oh look that she
had the audacity to do that to me what
should I do it's too late now when we
haven't talked since she announced the
name okay this is what you do oh you got
on the phone or you meet up with her and
you scream at her oh my god you either
ask her to change the name and if she
doesn't you are no longer her friend
this is the thing you don't have her
changing in you are no longer her friend
so it doesn't matter what the hell she
names her kids your kids are never gonna
meet this is the thing though I wouldn't
say make her change the name because
it's gonna become a huge fight and then
the names gonna be tainted and like
you're not even gonna want it when you
have a son so like I don't know I think
like my this is how I would play it I
would be completely done with this girl
forever never talked to her again and
let her have the name like and come up
with a better name no or keep the name
never talked to her again but she's out
of your life so who cares if a random
person that you don't know whose kid has
the same name as your kid right like I'm
sure there's gonna be another kid out
there named Francesca I don't know and
then like when you have your kid like
make sure it's really smart and that it
like skips a few grades so it's older in
school and the world would be like you
stole his name yeah do that okay it's
like the moral of the story never speaks
for being brave about your fertility
struggles I feel like a lot of people
are like embarrassed Ameri Sado to talk
about it and like when I hear like
people struggles I think it's so
empowering and I make
like really sad it I just like wanna
help ya oh my god also I read this fan
theory about friends yesterday basically
the three girls who are in the show one
of them is pregnant as a surrogate for
her brother she gives birth to triplets
you beauty then Rachel gets pregnant
with Ross and is a single mom and then
Monica adopts two kids because she can't
get pregnant and I never noticed how
like they all got like unconventional
ways of having kids and I read a fan
theory that they did on purpose and like
as a message to women to like you know
their unconventional ways of having
children and all three are beautiful
unacceptable that's nice I know made me
really like it and I didn't believe it
because then as I talk about this group
every day we have the friends fan group
you fell asleep and someone did like a
whole post and it made me really
depressed why she's like I'm writing a
paper on friends and how it's actually
like misogynistic and sexist can you
comment below some moments that like
grab DS arnott and like definitely there
are moments when I'm like this is
homophobic because like they make it
seem like being gay is a terrible cuz
Ross's ex-wife becomes lesbian and they
like joke about it all the time I'm like
it's definitely umma phobic but like I
just don't wanna hear it you know I know
that they're always fat shaming Monica
because she'd see that like I know I get
it like I don't want to be inundated by
that like that was a time when you could
say what you wanted and I got please
like I just I don't want to know please
don't ruin it for me then I read all the
comments and like it's making me really
depressed I'm sorry
sorry next story [ __ ] co-worker
I hate these [ __ ] I hate co-workers
that's why I don't work I currently work
at a university and I've been in my
position for about two years now there
is a particular co-worker of mine let's
call her Sally [ __ ] Holly and she
drives me insane she's so rude to me and
is constantly demanding things for me
even though she is not my boss I have
talked to my boss about this multiple
times and she has always told me that I
don't have to listen to her because she
is not my boss but when I ignore Sally
or tell her no and yells at me and is
extremely degrading to me in front of my
other co-workers my boss always says
that she has quote talks with Sally
about her behavior but I'm not too sure
about that I feel like there are small
periods of time where she kind of steps
back but it usually never lasts long and
has been and it has been especially bad
this week and last and I've had it up to
here with how she treats me it makes for
an extremely hostile work environment
and I am honestly miserable I love what
I do but I cannot deal with her
and the environment anymore I really
don't want to find the new job because I
love what I do but I ever gonna recently
begun applying to different jobs because
I think it's good for me to work it
isn't good for me to work in such a
toxic environment and so far no issues
have been resolved even though I always
report it to my boss what should I do
okay whatever you do make sure you like
write a record of it because like with
HR like if you have an inter work
conflicts like you have to make sure the
whole thing's on record so whatever you
do don't talk to her like email it write
it in a letter so there's proof no
charge don't go director Bakshi might be
giving this [ __ ] some preferential
treatment also after you go to HR say
things continue this way because like
your HR division is corrupt or something
give this picture takes of her own
medicine like you surviving two guys on
her death fight fire with fire an eye
for an eye as Confucius would say
whenever I hear fight fire with fire
I think I'm not seeing to me girls if
you fight fire with fire you'll just get
burned when she's at the mathlete thing
against that girl Catholic school but
very underrated I know it's like and
then I realized if you fight fire with
fire you'll just get burned okay yeah
but you've already been burned so what's
another burn at least you get to hurt
you know I'm saying she's already
thinner my Sally so even if you get more
burns like at least she burned her and
maybe the burn will stop her from
burning others because she didn't like
how it felt to be burned
I just hate people who like take
advantage of like other people who are
not confrontational and like are just
not that they're doormats but like
they'll just to avoid any conflict I'll
just do what you said you know and I'm
kind of like that like I hate conflict
so I'll just like i'll withstand like a
bunch of Treach in order to just like
not have to talk to someone but then I
get to a point where I'm like get a
spoon in my ass totally you should be
giving out spoons like you know totally
because then your own because anyway
make it easier for people to just eat
your ass and you wouldn't have to wait
for them to do it like you could be like
even you can eat when I immediately
he'll know I did not leave the Southside
serpents for this okay Jackie when you
think of like when you visualize grab a
spoon and in my ass
what do you visualize is I visualize
something so specific it's funny because
they had this conversation with Zack the
other day because I think some one of us
said like eat my ass cuz now our whole
family is discussing and we say no and
like I want credit and then we were
discussing like whether he would need it
I've organized or a spoon because it's
like are you hey butchey are you open up
the hole and spooning it out so I get
what you say spoon fork and nice you're
like carving Chiba cheeks is your carbon
chain which is cuter but it's not what I
think about I want to talk about
Vanderpump rules because I finally
caught up oh my god nasty benefi bros
Vanderpump rules being in part to Lala
okay a whole lot of Health overnight
like everyone like respect lalala as
much as I'm Samantha brown eats her ass
and Martin Scorsese watches veteran
brawls like I never thought me and
Martin Scorsese would have anything in
common but here we are yeah yeah that
was crazy and it's just like whenever
they talk about Randall whenever they
talk about Lala it's with utmost respect
everyone we love and we met him because
they like want to keep going on the
private plane except for she like now
well I like how does this like power and
influence where it's like she's telling
that to Annie and like annie has
deference towards Lala like when she's
like Martin Scorsese watches this show
like Andy wouldn't have known that
without her it's very weird and Lala's
like living for this newfound respect
and she thinks she's on the same level
as Lisa Vanderpump and she made a weird
analogy when she was like I mean Lisa we
know like when we buy Chanel bags it's
like you just know and that was a little
crazy um but you know maybe it's just
the end of it but like I've always said
the dynamics of the Vanderpump rules
cast similar to The Bachelor it's like
it's so sensitive because like it was
built on this like respect hierarchy
with Lisa Vanderpump at the top but now
all these kids are like celebrities they
have money to have careers and like they
don't need to waitress at Sur anymore
they don't need that respect from Lisa
Vanderpump so it's all very volatile and
now Lala is like completely disrupting
that were like she's on the same playing
field as Lisa yeah they both have like
like she can be a real housewife of
Beverly Hills in few years time but then
Lisa is obviously threatened by it
because she was like well you know I
work hard for my money where he's just
used to [ __ ] like she's so kind of
sending right and I thought all season
like wow it was like so feminist and
like so apparently empowering and I
thought we all agreed that it was great
right and like when they were like
literally and the introduced her as like
the Gloria Steinem of Vanderpump rules
yes and everyone was like here for it
and then on the reunion apparently like
now to this
get back know what everyone's like well
it's not my brand to feminize I'm like
I'm so done with like people having
different versions of feminists I mean
why don't know what feminism is all
women are great and they can do what
they want and they can use their body
for sex or use it for power or use their
mind everybody can do what they want if
you I don't you hooker I'm so here for
it as long as it's legal to want to be a
businesswoman good for you like it's all
the same yes that's feminism equality
amongst women just like I felt like
people were well I just I just realized
with him and I just came up with like a
brilliant feminism ideal I'm ready
ideology modern feminism has become so
obsessed with becoming equal to men
which by the way we totally should be
and [ __ ] everyone who disagrees but
we've lost sight of all women being
equal to each other like now there's
like a hierarchy amongst women whereas
like if you're a fortune 500 CEO like
you're not as good as a fortune 500 CEO
with three kids who breastfeeds at her
desk you know II mean like no no they're
all the same and the hookers here too we
are all people thousand seven ISM I just
figured it out can you figure out how to
really like just steal it in two
sentences that are really coherent a
thesis if someone wants to put it in the
toaster screw because like I'm not
really much of a writer girl that'll be
great you're such a writer girl honestly
like that whole brighter girl phrase is
the best thing um you didn't watch your
honey last night but Karen's getting
back to her writer girl reads and she's
taking a break and I was like and she's
like writing a column for Cosmo question
mark more from Vanderpump rules the Katy
accident Tom moment was so sweet I
literally was crying mm-hmm
and like everyone just like loves Katie
now and she's a she's a great character
and I think she's a good like moral
compass for the show that's like where
everyone can be friends with her and
she's like now that she's married she's
just kind of like elevated up kind of
you know looking down on the group and
making sure everyone's doing okay I have
two things I want to say so now I don't
like to rock okay
conspiracy theory conspiracy theory and
then what first thing I'll talk about
now is oh so scheana said she was like
well you know you got a lot of flack on
social media last year so you're
basically just pretending she said that
to Katie like you're just pretending
this year to like have changed and like
that really pissed me off because like I
totally understand like being able to
see yourself for like a third party like
perspective and see you like being mean
to people and like being not in a good
place and like wanting to change like
yes probably the flack on social media
didn't help like that really bothered me
that like scheana like made it seem like
Kate and that's like such a slanderous
thing to say like you're not really
change like you're just faking yeah and
I think also that's not necessarily like
a bad day
say you're doing something on like a
season of a show and you really feel
like it's the right thing and you're
going in and then half a year passes you
watch it back and the whole world is
saying that you are wrong it wouldn't
make you take stock of what you're doing
maybe you'll choose like nope I was
still right and you're all you [ __ ]
are wrong or you'll be like hey wait
maybe I was wrong let's give this girl a
chance and they think that's what you
did I don't think that's a bad thing
maybe they're to take what people say
people's opinions and criticism to take
it to heart another thing I want to talk
about is I read in the TRO search group
and I totally believe it a conspiracy
theory I saw did you okay so what people
are saying is that that storyline of Tom
randomly kissing a girl up on Guillou
and like Katie like not really caring
about it was made up like as a storyline
because it doesn't really add up why she
like really didn't care and like didn't
even punish him and like everything went
back to be normal so people are saying
like it didn't actually happen it was
just like a like a ploy for like a good
plot I'm of two minds on this because I
even feel like these this group in this
show has so much drama that they don't
need to fake it right or I literally
just two days ago watch the last three
episodes of the hills and I'm like it's
all fake well yeah like oh I don't know
the more research I do like the more
fakes yes the key is like it's I think
in those fake show on TV yeah but like I
don't expect CS to key to be super real
and it's like it's like the hill sort of
I don't think it's as fake as the hills
became because by the end they were all
just actors which is so crazy because
like Kristin Cavallari is an amazing
actress though she should win an Oscar
no Chloe you have to watch these
episodes like I would have totally
thought that she's in love with Berlin
and she's just going to lunch with Lo
and like these girls are not didn't
start as actresses where and they are
pretending to be two girls talking about
a boy that like Kristin you really think
is in love with and it's all fake so
congratulations to them deserves an
Oscar I don't know if Vanderpump rules
has to rely on fake drama yet I don't
know I sometimes I'm too naive in
sometimes I'm I'm too naive enough
what's the word they use it when that
woman in the cab
Jade is Chucky I know exactly talking
about add in Thai Lion King for the Lion
King where they talked to New Yorkers
about reviewing the show about reviewing
the choice oh my god a family remember
that everything on in a while one woman
is like I'm agitated New Yorker and I
loved it oh my that's so fun I sometimes
I'm a jaded reality television watcher
and sometimes I'm naive
I don't know you don't know what I am
because there are definitely some shows
that completely rely on like these job
drop like first season on Vanderpump
rules
I don't think a producer had to step in
for two seconds like they just let them
run wild but the first season of siesta
key literally had like a director yet
Alex Campos father yeah and they have
like a casting director too yeah they
have been casting a Kelsey was cast
someone in our toasters group has a
friend who was cast
she's a boyfriend and they're making her
date Garrett yeah look it's also crazy
but I'm fine with that the only thing
that's weird about it now that wasn't
weird about it with the hills is social
media where it's like you have to keep
up your fake life on social media and
then you're just like a big fat liar so
that makes it confusing and also like
these she has to keep people like our
beautiful young fun drunk people how
hard is it to have like actual drama
without having right plug it unless they
don't really know each other that's the
thing that grabbed Ramat with someone
you just met who got cast that's true
but like if you want to be like the top
dog you want a bit fun if you want
fabfitfun this is the price you have to
pay I didn't watch New York I mean if
jurors day tonight so let's tomorrow I'm
not here tomorrow oh [ __ ] oh you guys
I'm working on two co-hosts she had
people vote or just like she was
available see who's available cuz
they're both great you don't want to put
one down yeah
Jacky's go to Florida so you have to
watch kissing mutiny my I'm gonna watch
it tonight okay
do we have anything else no um roni was
great you should watch it ten minutes
let's just exhibitions okay I'm on
Facebook while you go on YouTube okay
hold on hold on guys it'll take you a
few minutes to see this because of the
lag but ask us some question any
questions you have for Jax right here
that's fine yeah but we have some extra
time we use to do this all the time
okay I'm just gonna have an answered a
question about myself and I guess since
the last episode of skinny today on the
show I need to pair all black more even
though I think I wear it a lot every
single day you know I always wear black
pants with like a colorful shirt a
colorful blouse like I think black is
like my color well Claudia back to you
literally so nice like you don't expect
cuz he's so like outrageous you meet him
and you're like think he's gonna like
kill you and spit in your face he's so
like what's the word disarming he's a
disarming how did I see is dis alarming
it's like you're like what a shock he's
is so nice like and actually genuinely
like a funny person I totally from
internet these people like a famous
something to meet them in real life and
they'll examine the corner on their
phone and like don't know how to
interact with people he's very social
very funny very like out there I really
like it I really like him to online and
offline
are we still accepting people for the
toasters groups yes yes everyday laundry
people yeah it's just like the the
vetting process is extreme so you might
get to kind but if you're if you're
serious about it come back again Oh
someone said there is a kissing booth
Messer post and they checked me in under
edit
oh great I don't get any updates on
merch actually yes I got some say I
forgot to tell you this I got some
samples coming in to see if we like this
company amazing and it's hoster I like
to support toaster business is we're
getting a neon sign from a toaster owned
business our merch is coming from a
toaster owned business like I like to
support women-owned business toaster
owned businesses totally okay what'd I
ever do say yes to the dress even though
your experience was an ideal I actually
would because I love that we have that
special and it was fun and if anyone's
asking I would do it what are your plans
with melissa gorga I don't want to say
because I don't want to jinx it but like
and because if it doesn't happen we'll
look like and then someone else might
steal the idea 100% don't say it's
incredibly iconic okay you teased about
Chicago Phoenix in your staff what was
that regarding well it's a tease so I
can tell you but like if you're in
Chicago in Phoenix like get your credit
card anything what would your timing be
like when June spring summer
photographers okay June I think I don't
want to work in July like I know that
synopsis I'm just like I want to break
so I think July I mean June is gonna be
like very show heavy for me and this
it's to Nashville show there's only like
20 tickets left so if you guys mark
those Chicago summers are hot are they I
don't know their note but they G right
on the water there's a nice breeze Jacob
says oh that's I'm Vicki will you ever
come that's not for you wait didn't meet
any tithing a person change your mind
about her on Real Housewives yes and it
did before we met her too but meeting
her again after this season just
confirmed what we already thought but
that she's amazing and that I love her
and I'm so conflicted but I love her
this question is from she might be one
of my favorite house I said we've been
and I agree
Christiane Johnson can we get some
morning toast joggers of course what are
joggers Pam trousers are like you know
how people wear like yoga pants how it's
like pants like that's joggers we should
do that with toast to a massage yeah all
now that I think about it I think sure I
was like it was an ode to Kanye because
years ago he was on like a team like a
chief Allen or something and they were
like what's the future of a fashion and
he was like joggers really he was before
everyone we clip on our ears before
everyone was wearing my pants um hold on
oh are we and me in bed never going on a
honeymoon like honestly I don't know I
just like I don't anytime
is this a skirt that I'm wearing no you
guys skirt its culottes because I have
any more of these cool essence the first
day when I took a beating friends do you
not know that Jackie puts the cooling
cool hats we Jackie people are kind of
upsetting you about my outfit up to the
OK Magazine party like that crazy I'm so
sure I saw the comments like that Wow
Jackie you really took a fashion really
didn't pay off here but you know keep at
it I literally thought my outfit was
like so simple and so cute and by the
way people are like wow you're gonna
regret this in a few years and I have to
be honest I've worn that outfit before
two years ago when we were in LA at
shikou knees and I loved it then and I
love it now I'm gonna love it two years
from now if it's not for you that's okay
also justice for those boots because
they're actually adorable they didn't
photograph well yeah because but on the
side they have buttons they're mosquito
and there's like so Erica Jane and I'm
obsessed with them and I've had them for
two years I love them two years ago and
I love them sometimes when I go to like
an event when I know I'm gonna get my
photo taken and like I don't look great
I'm like I really don't feel bad about
it cuz I'm like every celebrity like
you're not a real celebrity of like ugly
pictures early in your career so I'm
like this is fine no totally and it's
like I like looking back at photos I
mean like oh my god that was the trend
then but all I was wearing was a little
black dress and and a little pink like
someone from the 50s would wear so would
you ever get a dog and good for your
cousin I would love to do that but I
think I said on the show that Zach won't
let us get a King Charles Cavalier
spaniel because they shed and if we're
not getting not to spaniel not
interested I'm someone else my highlight
it's wax up how do you pronounce it
that's what's up by benefit that's so
good um have I picked my wedding date no
that's what I'm trying to nail down this
week I like once you do that and just
like bringing the caterer to the venue
like you could take like a serious break
oh this is a good question that we've
actually never spoken about have either
of you ever dyed your hair and this is
crazy but no no never not a highlight
nothing like a year ago I got into the
groove like really wanting to dye my
hair like dark black and then also have
eyebrows to match and mom was like are
you kidding you have like great hair
don't touch it so I didn't yeah that's
like none
none of our sisters have ever gotten
highlights a little way none of us ever
had braces either
we're so natural urges our people want
to know what we're doing for the royal
wedding
honestly Jack he's going away what have
we got really so before I booked this
trip I asked Claudia if even if I wasn't
going away what we do would we be doing
something and the answer is now it's too
early and like what it's either like I
can't go out and drink because I've to
meet up at 7:00 a.m. or I stay up the
whole night and have to like do ecstasy
to stay alive and it's like what we're
gonna put our phones on us on the couch
and you're gonna watch us live for three
hours watching TV no we'll just talk
about it after that I promise I will
have premium Instagram story countdown
so will the toasts because I'll be
watching it live from Florida what what
are some other towns that we want to
take the show to everywhere this is a
global towns nono countries really we're
a global brand it's true we need to like
what a show and like Montreal and then
we're global yeah
how did Jacob get his position for the
show very regular like a good person he
emailed us his resume when I make a
person know like I said we're hiring I
hate we people's like right let me send
the resume like I'm a hiring so we got
like a hundred resumes and we read like
five of them and like the lottery like
he was just luck I went and good time
yeah and then we went to lunch and I
just loved that we were like hiring a
boy it's just like so crazy you know to
me and yeah and he's fantastic we need
to do an episode with Jacob like or
maybe on the patreon if he's down if
you're down Jacob you're down okay why
isn't Olivia still there we miss her we
miss her too and there's so much work to
be done now that she's not here but like
she's a Big Time magazine editor with
like a very serious job and she can't
like produce our little Instagram show
anymore right
which is like fair you know what made us
start the show I think it was that we
had a name and that we got the
opportunities we're like we'd be good
okay I want to clarify something because
we keep saying we got this opportunity
and we didn't get an opportunity to
start a social morning show that was our
idea we got an opportunity to do
whatever the hell we wanted on social
company at a company with like resources
so what would you want to do and we were
like we want to do a morning show that's
just on social media it seems like a
no-brainer but no one has done it yet so
like I just want to say like good for us
like I'm looking at the YouTube stream
like this is high-quality and these
chairs are so cute like I'm just
really impressed by how we got on our
feet so quickly no totally we've come
very far I just wish the only thing the
set is so cute in like it's a day like
today we're like neither of us match the
set and like me I wish we can always
should have you should have uniforms for
the show I would be so pajamas I'm like
oh no like like so whoever's more like
what they wear it like the Beverly Hills
Hotel like those little cute things with
wear different things but that match the
set and then we can wear it every day we
don't have to worry about what we're
wearing I'm so down and then every
episode will look the same and nothing
will look like dated we're gonna be
sorry and then they'll be part of our
merch store oh that's a good idea
but we're getting any on side which I'm
really excited about the time the
morning toast we need that too am I
going to Disney when I'm in Florida no I
wish I'm just looking looking at our
show and I'm just like this rocks
totally what I want to watch a show
Claud do you both always wear your
engagement rings or do they get in the
way um I literally never wear it and
like I always forget and my fingers get
so swollen so quickly like if I have
like literally like any soy sauce I
can't wear my rings for like a month I
never take mine off because I'm not a
jewelry person so I don't ever think to
put on sleep I sleep in it I do
everything you know I don't but I'm
gonna get a big I take it off like to do
stuff either
I'm 100% gonna lose it or I'm never
gonna put it on again so I'm gonna
forget because I don't like to think
about jewelry I picked out a band I
think but it's gonna be for my birthday
and when I get that I'm never gonna take
that one off oh that's nice what is yeah
it's definitely my jewelry and it's I
don't know like a bands Claud we should
go do a show in Nantucket Claudia and I
went to Nantucket once and it was the
craziest trip honestly like it was worth
it because we got the phrase in tune
with what's necessary from our trip to
Nantucket but it was way up to today
like who got yelled at Claudia he's
probably in a military school he's
definitely not boarding school we're
like robes
would you ever to a reality show it
would depend on the circumstances and
would have to be like with people that
we know already and trust because right
now like we do our own show we have say
and we're not edited - no one can make
us like look like a different way that
we are honestly like you probably get
more content from our show our
instagrams our stories then you would
from like a chopped-up 22 minutes where
we have to pretend sound like I would do
it and like honestly at this point like
if we had wanted to do it we could have
done it a long time ago but like I'm not
that there seem to be on TV and like
like a fake show that like you know it
gets off the air and odds of it being
canceled are high yeah also but if I
think the only way we would do it like
not like for sure is if it were like
your Bravo only Bravo I wouldn't even do
it free really I guess I feel like he
shows get canceled more you know and
they're like the success rate is so low
and like I feel like with Bravo they
really give you a chance like ladies of
London season one like gin up great
ratings they brought it back for like
three more seasons and then like they
eventually killed him but like they got
four seasons out of them yeah would you
ever do like a toaster live broadcast
something from your wedding um I might
do a little something I had you guys I
haven't even begun to thought about like
where I'm getting married let alone how
much I'm gonna show of it this was a
good question did you watch Amy Schumer
on SNL yes I planned my whole night
around it forgetting that it starts at
11:30 and I could have like gone out to
dinner and come home and watch it and
been fine and I love her so much and
everything was good but like there was
no moment where I was like bowel Dover
and laughter laughing so hard and like
it was a little disappointing
but I still loved her and I it was
really good but I watched some of the
clips on YouTube and I just I didn't
know if I think they're funny but like
there was one sketch like where they did
The Handmaid's Tale like Sexsmith City
version and like I don't watch him
myself right cause I know it would have
been so fun whether it was still really
funny but I don't watch and meets
outside again missing some contacts a
hundred percent that cute anything was
fun let's do it like once a week
Oh totally so many more and one more
because it's almost 7:30 um
will we be bringing back baskets of
people Oh should we did you us like that
I feel like at the end it got like a
little stupid Jacob loves it okay Jacob
it's your job um Claudia how tall are
you guys everyone always says I how tiny
you are okay I am look on an average day
five feet some days I like literally
shrink below to the fours and then some
days I'm like one eyes like stand up
straight I'm like 5 1 so like let's call
it even at 5:00 I am and I've been every
time I go to the doctor for the past
like six years 5 foot and 3/4 and even
so we're both so sure we're both very
very short I love it let it be known
that I am a little bit taller than you
like a quarter of an I don't never let
me match it when you're like a giraffe I
don't want to be Toby this is being
short ask you we remember when we
measured ourselves on the show we'd be
like a really really tall girl or like
really like you're afraid
Dana how shortest wait four eight and
she's like so cute well I think I'd
rather be well I guess if you're really
really tall you can be a model but what
if you're really really tall and and
you're not a model
wait no and like just the amount of boys
you could date like significantly goes
down
yes that's true and like I think I I
think I would be a good Dana sighs no I
think it's like so I love being short
and I think I'm like the perfect short
cuz I'm like I'm a short girl like but
what are we talking about really really
tall over six feet five ten I think no I
think it has to be over six feet because
she's under five like we're talking four
eight versus I think we got to go six
four but what no no yeah be a girl cause
510 is really tall yeah no but that's
just tall that's not really tall oh
Christmas tree that's it yeah it's six
feet and four eight six feet or 5 foot
that's equal you mean no I guess not in
five foot five foot or six foot no for
eight five five is the median you're
either five foot or six foot or you're
for eight or six it's not equal it's
like you're making into math like
because just like for eight is really
short and six feet is really tall that's
it okay just because of how I've lived
my life in my personality I'd rather
continue to be short you know my
personality is looks so for sure you
know what's weird to me when people who
are shorter like complain about being
short or like try and look tall and
pictures and it's like who gives a [ __ ]
like I understand tall girls like
wanting to be short cause like boys like
if they're taller it's like awkward but
like short girls like you're fine you
know but like tall girls - it's like
that's literally the one thing you have
no control over like what do you care
you know the first time I ever went
viral on the internet was talking about
this exact subject in a much more
offensive way and I got in a lot of
trouble on writer okay I have a question
for you what would you rather be like a
really tall girl a really short boy tall
girl because totals are beautiful it's
not bad to be tall it looks like there's
some challenges that come with it but
like you're like you're slender and lean
and like you can use are being taught
being a tall girls not a bad thing being
a sharp boy like a really sharp boy not
good
I'm not talking about this because I
wrote an article on my website like a
long time ago like I did a blog post I'm
like how just sucks to be sharp away and
like literally it was called our short
it was a reddit sub group for short
people and literally I got messages to
kill myself like really crazy like I
will never ever ever talk about this
again thank you so much for joining us
this has been the morning toast
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time Jackie's not here tomorrow I'm
finding a co-host it's gonna be so
incredibly late
I will announce it on Instagram the
morning trust goes live on Facebook and
YouTube so make sure you like us on
Facebook and your subscribe to us on
YouTube and then we also are available
and the podcast app a little later in
the day so make sure your subscribe to
us and the podcast app and leave a five
star review about how gorgeous amazing
and slender we are we hope I didn't
offend you too badly the show thank you
so much for tuning in I'm Claudia shy
girl no job I'm Jackie Ashley takeo
problems and the next time I see you
Megan Markin Megan market will be a
princess Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck Chuck
Chuck Chuck Chuck